imaginez votre frustration si vous aviez
une solution
à la crise climat qu'ils menacent de
ravager la planète et de générer un
conflit social à côté duquel la deuxième
guerre mondiale passerait pour un jeu
d'enfant
mettez vous à la place des défenseurs
solitaire de l'énergie nucléaire
c'est comme ça que démarre à un article
qui a été écrit en décembre 2015 dans un
magazine américain peu après la
signature des accords de paris et dans
lequel je suis mentionné
la cap 21 a été la première coop à
accueillir très largement l'ensemble des
acteurs mondiaux sur les négociations
climat étaient présents les religions
petit est grande les maires des grandes
métropoles mondiales les entreprises
aussi et jusqu'aux populations indigènes
la holding à l'initiative a tenu son
colloque à cette occasion le charbon
était représenté le ministre saoudien du
pétrole et des ressources avaient
répondu à l'invitation
tout le monde était là sauf
le nucléaire
ni la filière ni ses représentants
ni même le mot
pas même sur le pavillon de la france
qui était le pays d'accueil et qui est
le seul encore aujourd'hui pays du g20
avoir décarbonés intégralement son
système électrique grâce au nucléaire
pas un mot parce qu'il n'était pas
invité
parce qu'ils étaient trop tabou
alors que avec l'hydroélectricité
c'est de très loin une des plus
importantes énergies bas carbone dans le
monde
cette photo a été prise il ya quelques
mois à la dernière marche pour le climat
à laquelle les voies du nucléaire ont
participé la petite fille que vous
pouvez voir à droite c'est ma fille
d'une de quatre ans elle tenait
absolument à tenir la banderole coeur et
d'une m'a dit à cette occasion
maman quand tu seras morte la reine du
nucléaire ça sera moi
alors rien ne va dans cette phrase et
pour ne pas épiloguer
indéfiniment sur les subtilités de cette
phrase édifiante j'ai regardé d'une et
je lui ai dit écoute
non ça ne sera pas nécessaire d'une
quand tu seras grande
on aura résolu le problème on aura
réussi la transition énergétique
en 2050 d'une aura 32 ans
moi je ne serai pas encore morte et
d'ici à 2050 en 28 ans il faudra qu'on
ait effectivement résolu le problème
c'est à dire remplacer 90 % de notre
consommation énergétique mondiale
carbonée c'est à dire les fossiles
pétrole gaz charbon et la biomasse et
qu'on est maintenue et développée
évidemment les 10% d'énergie bas carbone
dont nous disposons déjà
hydroélectricité nucléaire éolien
solaire géothermie énergies marines
je vous laisse apprécier l'évolution
depuis 1990 un 2019 et les proportions
respectives de ses différentes formes
d'énergie qui sous tendent notre
consommation énergétique mondiale et
tout ce que nous sommes et tout ce que
nous faisons
un problème en réalité trois problèmes
stabiliser le climat bien sûr mais aussi
assurer dignité bien-être à l'humanité
toute entière et préserver les
écosystèmes et la biodiversité
trois objectifs indissociables
trois objectifs que nous n'atteindrons
que si nous les visons simultanément
ces objectifs ont plusieurs solutions
qui contribue alors
alors alors à leur résolution qui sont
toutes les énergies bas carbone dont on
a parlé d'un moment dont le nucléaire le
nucléaire qui a plusieurs atouts
considérables à faire valoir et pour
chacune d'entre elles des atouts qui
sont concrets qui sont opérationnels qui
sont disponibles et qui ont fait leurs
preuves
ces solutions bas carbone les voilà ça
c'est un zoom sur la petite bande de 10%
du grave que je vous ai montré tout à
l'heure
elles doivent être déployés
impérativement tout ensemble autant que
possible aussi profondément que possible
dans autant de géographique possible
maintenant nous arrivons sur un
quatrième problème un très gros problème
qui est que une très importante partie
de tous les efforts qu'ils ont pu être
menée à l'échelle mondiale sur la
transition énergétique consiste à
remplacer une de ces solutions bas
carbone qui le nucléaire par d'autres
les énergies solaire éolienne
neutre étant toujours pas le problème de
fond qui sont les énergies fossiles et
les émissions de gaz à effet de serre
que leur combustion génère
alors effectivement voilà à quoi a
ressemblé une partie importante de nos
efforts pour la transition énergétique
ces vingt dernières années en
particulier en europe cette photo vous
pouvez trouver assez largement sur
internet en ce moment représente une des
symbolique très forte liée à l'énergie
22 c'est à dire la transition
énergétique menée par l'allemagne et qui
en a inspiré beaucoup d'autres cette
transition énergétique et qui vise à
rompre à l'utiliser les renouvelables
pour remplacer le nucléaire plutôt que
pour remplacer les énergies fossiles
vous comprenez maintenant pourquoi aussi
c'est peut-être une réponse à la
frustration que l'on entend et qu'on
ressent bien légitimement malgré tous
les investissements extrêmement
considérables qui ont été menés et on
parle de plus de 800 milliards d'euros à
l'échelle seulement de l'union
européenne malgré la prise de conscience
la mobilisation dont vous faites partie
malgré l'engagement des entreprises et
des politiques qu'on peut questionner
qu'on peut discuter mais qui existe et
qui est réel malgré tout cela les
émissions ne décroisse que lentement
trop lentement et rebondissent à chaque
crise et on va en avoir de plus en plus
la politique énergétique française ne
fait pas exception cette citation est
tirée d'un rapport de la cour des
comptes de mars 2018 effet un bilan
intermédiaire de l'a3 transition
énergétique de 2015 qui est encore
applicable
la cour des comptes vous le savez ne
porte pas de jugement l analyse et
retranscrit les faits
face à la menace russe la transition
énergétique allemande persiste et signe
en ce moment comme je vous parle le
gouvernement a réitéré son intention de
fermer ces trois dernières centrales
nucléaires d'ici à la fin de l'année et
de relancer très fortement et à coût de
milliards de subventions le charbon est
la limite qui constituent la majorité de
leur approvisionnement électrique
il est utile de rappeler à ce stade que
ces centrales charbon génère une
pollution de l'air qui est responsable
de plusieurs milliers de morts par an en
europe
et qui émet des gaz à effet de serre à
hauteur de plus de 130 x serait qu'une
centrale nucléaire peut émettre
la société civile
porteuse engagés pour la transition
énergétique
traditionnellement également porteuse de
valeurs d'écologie et de changement qui
a aujourd'hui un influence directe sur
les processus réglementaires et
législatifs cette société civile ne fait
pas exception non plus vous voyez ici le
directeur général de greenpeace france
qui a fait l'actualité très récemment en
menant une action pour dénoncer la
construction de la centrale nucléaire de
flamanville 3
le même week-end le même week-end ou à
quelques centaines de kilomètres de là
était inauguré la centrale de l'audi de
landivisiau gaz pour laquelle total
energy va recevoir 40 millions d'euros
de subventions par an
c'est en réponse à ce quatrième problème
qui va freiner voire qui empêche la
résolution des trois autres que j'ai
décidé en mars 2018 de créer l'eau entre
les voies du nucléaire
les voies d'une claire c'est un canal la
société civile l'exigence citoyenne de
bénéficier dans de bonnes conditions
d'une des plus grandes avancées
scientifiques que l'humanité ait jamais
connu un message si vous pensez que le
changement climatique est suffisamment
grave que vous êtes prêts à tous les
efforts mieux que vous êtes prêts à
exiger tous les efforts des autres la
moindre chose que vous pouvez faire
c'est revisitez vos certitudes sur le
nucléaire
à la lumière des faits
un message et des citoyens des bénévoles
des gens normaux comme vous et moi
de tous les âges beaucoup de jeunes en
particulier qui ne portent pas en eux
les peurs qu'ont développé leurs aînés
dans les années 70 des gens qui ont
décidé que les histoires qu'on leur
racontais et l'imagerie qu'on leur
présenterai ne ferait pas forcément le
poids par rapport à la réalité qu'ils
avaient expérimenté eux mêmes ou bilan
qu'on pouvait tirer de 50 à 60 ans de
nucléaire mondiale et que les faits
avaient une valeur une valeur pour eux
et on l'espère une valeur pour les
autres
j'ai mis fin à ma carrière vous voyez là
on cadres exécutifs de l'industrie pour
devenir la porte parole une porte-parole
improbable d'un sujet qu'il l'était
encore plus sans jamais être payés pour
le faire pour plusieurs raisons la
première elle est importante c'est parce
que je savais de quoi je parlais j'avais
l'expérience et la compétence d'un sujet
qui me donner une certaine légitimité
pour apporter quelque chose
parce que quand vous voulez briser un
tabou
la première chose à faire c'est de
l'assumer vous même
parce que pour être honnête personne ne
voulait le faire personne ne l'aurait
fait et qu'il fallait que quelqu'un
commence
parce que aussi je n'étais pas un homme
blanc d'un certain âge et que je me
disais que mon message avait peut-être
un peu plus de chance de passer et
surtout parce que j'avais étudié pendant
longtemps plus de 15 ans en l'occurrence
les systèmes électriques et
et je m'inquiétais du changement
climatique comme vous dans cette salle
je crois et que j'avais compris que sans
nucléaire ma promesse a dû nous à
n'importe qui d'ailleurs serait un
mensonge si je disais qu'on allait y
arriver
l'objectif des voix du nucléaire c'est
combattre la désinformation
refonder le choix démocratique je vous
donne quelques exemples les déchets
nucléaire ne présentent pas de risque ni
pour l'environnement ni pour la
population ce ne sont pas des pollutions
les radiations issus de l'accident de la
centrale nucléaire de fukushima au japon
n'ont pas fait et ne feront pas de
victimes l'énergie nucléaire est
l'énergie la plus bas carbone de france
en comparaison de toutes les autres
les énergies éolienne et solaire sont
absolument indispensables et doivent
être développées autant que possible
parce qu'elles réduisent le nombre
d'heures pendant lesquelles les
centrales fossiles tourner par contre
elle ne les remplace pas il y aura
toujours besoin d'un socle nucléaire et
hydraulique pour assurer
l'approvisionnement
les temps changent
il aura fallu plus de quatre ans et
quelques crises pour être sincère pour
qu'on nous donne enfin la parole le
nucléaire est l'énergie la plus
décarbonés de france je vous lis dit et
redit mais 69% des 18-35 ans ne le
savent pas 69% des 18-35 ans en france
qui ont vécu toute leur vie avec 80% de
leur électricité d'origine nucléaire
pense que c'était énergie émet des gaz à
effet de serre et participe aux
changements climatiques alors que il met
le changement climatique en haut de
leurs préoccupations électorales
on est en démocratie
et il est aujourd'hui
aussi important que une solution
technique soit comprise et adopter
autant que d'en disposer
la science
les technologies ne sont rien d'autre
que de la science appliquée la science
appliquée ne peut l'être au bénéfice des
populations et de la planète que si ces
populations la comprennent si vous
voulez changer les choses ne méprisez
pas à la communication ne méprisez pas
vos donneurs d'ordre que sont les
citoyens les consommateurs
expliquez-leur ce que vous faites
pourquoi comment quelles sont les
alternatives dans quel objectif avec
quels bénéfices vous travaillez sur une
solution technique la science et la
technologie sont et vont être les outils
dont nous avons besoin pour affronter
ces trois grands objectifs que sont la
stabilisation du climat la préservation
de conditions dignes pour les humains et
la préservation des écosystèmes et de la
biodiversité
vous êtes ingénieur
trouver des solutions et dans votre adn
les faire comprendre va devoir devenir
votre responsabilité ne l'oublié pas